do you use any screenwriting software
final draft I'm a final draft guy okay
final draft is is the way to go as far
as I'm concerned okay so can you take us
through the process of using it I'm just
curious
you know what it's now it's just become
so instinctual like I was writing a
buddy of mine was working on a script
and he asked for help and he sent it to
me in word and I was so it was so
frustrating that I just transferred it
all over wrote it in final draft and
then gave it back to him so you can put
it back and wear it if you want but like
I'm gonna write in my format I just you
know I like the way it looks I
understand the borders you know it's
like I've been doing this for a long
time now I've been probably writing
scripts for over 20 years and that's
crazy to me that I've been doing
anything for 20 years but I have and at
least 18 of those has been with final
draft so it's just my quill and
parchment you know what I mean
right so what's your advice to writers
who don't want to use any type of
software they just want to write it in
pages or a word document I mean I feel
like it's kind of like what's the it's
like method acting you know like I
really don't care how you get there as
long as you get there you know but I
think it's easier with final draft and
it is the accepted industry standard so
you don't have to worry about it looking
funny because executives the number one
thing that you need to not do this is
the biggest landmine don't look like an
amateur especially if you're an amateur
so like if you're just starting out your
title page needs to look right you need
to you know your borders need to look
right it needs to be well structured it
needs to not be numbered the scenes need
to not be numbered that is a shooting
script not a selling script you know
like all of these little things that you
don't know you don't know you know are a
red flag because a lot of readers and or
development people they're not that
savvy right and so they're looking for a
reason to own their leather chair and if
they can spot something that you've done
that's amateurish you know they'll throw
you right out you know
there aren't many like there the guys
that are making these decisions there
aren't that many of them that are like
savvy and I've been around the block of
time or two and I was like I found a
diamond in the rough they're just
finding the diamonds that other people
have found you know what I mean they're
like he like this so I like it too
it's great cuz you know everybody's
worried about getting fired I think
that's accurate
am I gonna ruin my career in LA by this
you're saying that that you know it's
it's good to look professional and use
some and a lot of times you give
yourself away by not knowing something
you know and you have nobody gives you
the benefit of the doubt in this
business like nobody there's just too
many people there's too many people with
experience and there's too many people
clawing so like nobody's gonna be like
hey you know there's some typos but man
what a story
they just won't unless you are you know
like Cameron Crowe or you know Quentin
Tarantino and turn in the script would
they change the margins that's the only
way you get the benefit of the doubt if
they don't know you know they were
looking for a reason to hate your script
that's another reason why this structure
thing is so important especially when
you're first starting out because if you
make a choice to change that structure
they will not assume it was a choice
they will assume it was ignorance and
they won't get through page 10 like if
nothing happens by page 15 if the
inciting incident is not there on page
15 writer doesn't know what he's doing
even if that's not true at all
I think that's I think that's an
absolute true statement
you